all right we have a lot of ground to
cover tonight joining us first we begin
with Devon newness is the chairman of
the House Intelligence Committee is a
California congressman congressman you
say that you will move to hold the
Attorney General of the United States in
contempt of Congress explain how they
have been slow walking using redactions
in the name of national security that
turn out not to be true and how they
have been unwilling to answer Congress's
subpoena and how that is the
constitutional role of Congress thanks
Sean first of all you don't have enough
time left on your show in order for me
to get to all of the stonewalling that
DOJ and FBI have done throughout our
investigation let's just maybe pick a
few at the top just last week after six
weeks we discovered that for the first
time the American people now know that
James Comey testified before Congress
that he was not that that the FBI agents
that interviewed Flynn didn't think he
was lying took us six weeks for the FBI
and DOJ to get rid of those redactions
that was finally released late on a
Friday night if you go back to the
things that they've dealt with if you
look at with fusion GPS and getting
documents that were pertinent for that
for that fight that's just another good
example of you know the the fact that we
weren't able to figure out that the FBI
and DOJ actually knew that the Clinton
campaign and the Democratic National
Committee had paid for the dirt on how
long did they know that because we
didn't find out if I'm correct them for
a year later well look we believe that
they knew it they knew it basically from
the very beginning what that would mean
they knew that Clinton paid for it when
they've made the FISA application and
they never verified the Clinton dossier
by a foreign agent fight citing
unverified Russian sources they knew all
of this did they lie to a FISA judge
will they they know things here's the
funny thing is that they know things
they they know things that aren't true
like the fact that James Comey testified
and even said on Brett Bears show that
Republicans had started the dossier so
that wasn't true now what is true is is
that the Democratic Committee and the
Killary Clinton campaign paid for the
dirt but of course mr.
we didn't tell that to Congress because
Christopher Steele was not brought in I
saw that interview he was not brought in
until Hillary started paying that bill
correct well we don't know he had been I
think he had been a source before or be
he had been affiliated but the bottom
line is is that at this about the same
time the FBI started getting information
at the same time the DNC was paying mr.
steel so we know that much so now we get
to so let's get to where we're at today
we sent a letter two weeks ago to the
Department of Justice a classified
letter they ignored that letter we had
to then issue a subpoena
last week we issued a subpoena then
finally on Thursday they got back to us
and said they weren't going to comply
with the subpoena now over the course
the last few days they continue to leak
ridiculous stories release leaked
stories of classified meetings that
occurred at the White House that quite
frankly some of us weren't even aware of
these meetings but they're coming to us
with accusations that clearly had to
have been leaked by the Department of
Justice in the FBI so soon these
sessions in in contempt I look as far as
so I want to talk to mr. sessions so he
so the attorney general session said
today that he wants to discuss things
that's good I want to talk to him I
actually don't believe that mr. sessions
saw my letter I really don't I don't
think the Attorney General saw it so
then we had to move to the subpoena
which I'm sure he found out about that
but you know at the end of the day he's
in charge there I think there's enough
information now that the attorney that
South there now between what you saw in
the court that you had in your monologue
on Friday well I think the Attorney
General should I mean at some point the
recusal I've always ridiculous I am I am
befuddled and bewildered where the look
for example you know there's a great
piece by Andrew McCarthy why all the
secrecy
outrageous redactions to the Russia
report rod Rosenstein up to the final
minute we would never have gotten the
new Ness memo or the Grassley graham
report about FISA abuse because rod
Rosenstein according to my sources with
begging Paul Ryan not to hand that
information that you subpoenaed way in
advance and he waited to the last hour
to hand it over
why is rod Rosenstein doing this why are
they now the FBI
refusing to pursue the personal struck
page tax when we know there are gaps
missing in that and at what point do we
see this as an obstruction case well I
agree with you that they should just
stop digging I don't know what's going
on in their minds I mean there's enough
information out there now they should
know that what's occurred here now was
was was inappropriate they know that
they can't investigate themselves and so
you know if you want to actually get to
solving the problem just stop making the
problem worse what did you and in a
timely manner I mean just give us all
the information just give it to us so
that the investigators that have the
oversight role can properly go through
everything but when they the more that
they spread this out bit by bit by bit
the more ridiculous they look and the
more dishonest they look and the more
corrupt serve looks to the American
people if I've been wrong you I know you
follow the show is there I only have 20
seconds is there anything I've been
wrong about on this show because it's
now seems to everything is now falling
into place and we see what's happening
and rod Rosenstein said the Justice
Department won't be were re extorted
last word you have about twenty seconds
yeah that's a that statement was totally
ridiculous they just need to give us the
documents Shawn look this is going to
get a lot worse before it gets any
better there's a lot more information
out there that the American public has a
right to know and you have not been
wrong on anything that I've seen but
your but the you know what your
challenge is you haven't seen all the
information and use words right to see
it and it's worse unbelievable all right
sir thank you for the good work you're
doing to be transparent with the mayor
the American people